but what about the women that like you  if uh like scenario like you find like  your dream girl you're in love with her  and then you find that like she can't  provide a family for you no matter how  old she is then you have to go through  adoption anyway so why is like age a  hard cap I think it's just like  likelihood I mean like geriatric  pregnancy starts at 35  um  ninety percent of your eggs are gone by  30. yeah and so it's just like if if you  get a 25 year old or 22 year old that's  less likely to happen but there's like  there's still that chance that she's  like completely infertile you know what  I mean so like I don't know in my eyes  like to touch a lot on that